little bug little bird
crap out of me I couldn't resist
tell me about this new school with yours
right now I'm just trying to fit in it's
kind of in my motto versus I left my old
school Julia you did not leave your old
school you're expelled for being cruel
to another boy I'm sure your father has
told you stories about when I was a
young girl
he says you don't really like to talk
about it I don't
but now I think for your sake I must
[Music]
excuse me oh God what is he doing I saw
this on your desk thanks you're welcome
I didn't even know his name look at this
freak
but we had in common one crucial thing
it's really good
for a Jew
we had both seen how much hate people
are capable of one of the children's
missing find out and how much courage it
took to be kind you need to come with me
right now I know I out
you stay with us okay
I'm in Dark Times
those small things remind us of our
Humanity
I would like to visit New York tonight
sure open your eyes
you're the prettiest person I've ever
met
thank you
forget many things in life but you never
forget kindness
because when kindness can cost you your
life
comes like a miracle